[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kitten
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest this week is
the creator of Dilbert who's now
reinvented himself about three or four
years ago when he predicted that Donald
Trump would be elected based on what he
described as his skillset and we're
going to delve into that and a lot more
with the brilliance go Adam Scott thank
you so much for joining us thanks
revelry it's great to have you here
listen before we we get into the
interview you have a huge audience
obviously in the United States but not
many people will or fewer at least
people will know who you are over here
in the UK so don't do us a favor tell us
a little bit about how you are where you
are today what's been your journey
through life well I started out as a
corporate cubicle dweller and I invented
the the Dilbert cartoon strip which does
by the way run in some papers in Great
Britain I don't know which ones off the
top of my head but of course it's on the
internet at Dilbert calm and so it's in
2000 newspapers I expect by next month
that will be in 100 newspapers because
that's probably all that will be left
after we're done with this ugliness
and I pivoted as you said to talking
about persuasion because I have a
background as a trained hypnotist and
I've been studying persuasion in all its
forms for decades as part of my my job
as a writer it's it's a good skill to at
your writing talent and so I started
talking about Donald Trump and his skill
for persuasion and that sort of dragged
me into the larger political
conversation where I spend most of my
time now yeah and you do a daily kind of
coffee with scott adams stream where you
talk and analyze about many of the
things that are happening i really
recommend people check that out go ahead
francis no and i was going to say that
was very very interesting as I've
watched a lot of your interviews Scott
and when you came out and said you know
Trump has
a particular set of skills which are
very very useful to him all of a sudden
people misinterpreted that as you be in
support of Trump in particular people on
the left well yeah for your audience I
identify personally I'm socially Lefter
than the left you can get you know in
our country the left would say you know
you should let me turn off my phone you
should legalize marijuana and I say yes
and mushrooms and maybe look at the LSD
so I'm left ER than our left when it
comes to things like that you know gay
marriage why didn't we do that a long
time ago but when it comes to money and
you know orders and politics
I favor whatever works so if somebody
can give me a good argument for why one
plan works I don't care where it came
from and that's interesting but it's
also not only that it's the people on
the left and by the way I consider
myself to be on the left I'm a former
schoolteacher people's reaction to you
on the left that automatically if you
say Trump has any sorts of qualities
which of course he does you know that
automatically means you're in favor of
him and then you're discarded from the
trolley
yeah yeah we're a very tribal over here
and I've tried to keep that distinction
you know that I'm talking about his
skill set but that only goes so far
just just to be clear once someone is
the president you know be it Obama via
Trump I always support the president I
mean you'd have to do something pretty
pretty bad to lose my support once you
have the job you know because I tend to
support the leader in those conditions
especially now in the middle of an you
know global crisis so if he asked me do
I support the president unambiguously
yes now that doesn't mean that
everything he does is gonna you know be
great in my mind I had lots of
criticisms about the the beginning of
the coronavirus stuff but in general yes
I support him and will support him and
if he's replaced by something else I'm
gonna support that person too that's
such an American approach in the UK we
have exactly the same but the other way
around the moment someone
becomes the leader we immediately stop
supporting them that's that's how it
seems to work well I separated
supporting from whether I criticize or
not I'm never gonna turn off criticism
but actually you have even in your
recent videos when Donald Trump made the
comment about you know I don't want the
cruise ship to land in the US because
the that would affect my numbers you
were extremely critical of him at the
time so you that's one of the reasons I
think a lot of people enjoy your stuff
because you're very balanced and you
maintain a kind of neutrality to it but
before we before we get into the
coronavirus because I we want to talk to
you about that at length just for those
people who may not be familiar with you
going back to the prediction of Trump's
election and and everything we've seen
since what were the skills that you as a
hypnotist as a persuasion expert saw in
him that gave you that confidence which
you had very early on way before most
people that this was going to happen
yeah a lot of the things they his
biggest critics were complaining about
and saying well here's an example of why
he's incompetent and her stupid giri's
lost or whatever were also the tools of
persuasion so his simplicity
for example his repetition of simple
things his use of visual persuasion I
don't need to improve border security
I'm gonna build a wall it's a big
beautiful wall and it's gonna have a
Doran and and every everybody gets to
visualize their own wall which is
classic hypnosis technique had he said
it's gonna be a big brick wall or
specified at that level then people say
I don't know I'm not seeing a brick and
then they'd have something to argue with
so the perfect perfect sweet spot for
persuasion is that it's a wall but I'm
not going to tell you what that looks
like and then you imagine your own wall
so he does persuasion the the top things
the best so if you were going to
persuade somebody to do something fear
would be the number one best thing you
could do beyond that identity so he's
got the fear of you know anything coming
in from the outside he's got the
identity make America great again he's
got the best slogan probably of all time
even though I guess Reagan you know you
could give him credit for using it as
well but I don't think anybody used it
as well as this president you know from
from the hat to the slogan to the to the
digital persuasion that you see now
that's just so horrible class and and he
was completely transparent about his
strategy I mean he told people in
advance watch what I do I'm gonna take
all the oxygen out of the room and
there'll be nothing left and that's what
he did he just starved everybody of
oxygen it was about the time that he
gave Jeb Bush his famous now nickname
low-energy Jeb and that was the moment I
said it's over you just found your
president because most people said well
that's funny and non-standard and he's
just insulting somebody and at the time
I was yelling as loud as I can no no no
okay this is not normal what you saw is
one of the best pieces of persuasion
it's gonna go down in history it's just
one of the best and I could see it
immediately because I could see that
every day from that point on you would
never see Jeb Bush the same before that
I thought you know there's a calm cool
experienced executive that's exactly the
kind of person I want in an emergency
calm cool and then as soon as Trump said
he's low-energy that's all I could see
I'd say you know he is kind of
low-energy compared to Trump and then
contrast is another big principle and
Trump uses that so well another thing he
does is he goes really hard at his
critics no matter what and he goes
really hard in the good way to his
friends no matter who they are so you
could be kim jeong-hoon you could be a
typical doesn't matter if you say
something nice about this president he's
gonna call you out in public praise you
you know do you a favor so that's
another trick of persuasion I first saw
this when I was working my corporate job
the character who became the Alice
character in my comic strip she was the
first one who showed that to me she
would go really hard at the people that
were in her way
she'd talk to their boss only she could
fire
I mean she would be brutal but if you
did her a favor
she would buy you flowers and she would
go talk to your boss and say you know
you've really got a superstar here you
should think about promoting this person
now if you only did one or the other of
those that would be good you know
threatening people will get you some
action complimenting people gets used
some action but when you become famous
for those extremes as she did she became
the most effective person in the company
because that people would look at her
and say well I got a choice I have all
these things I can do today I can either
do something for for this person and
I'll get a compliment and maybe a raise
and if I don't I'm in trouble
so she effectively started managing you
know even things the managers weren't
managing because she would do the same
thing to her bosses she would make sure
her boss got a compliment to her boss's
boss and vice versa if it didn't work
out
so that's that's the Trump technique he
goes hard in both directions and makes
you know it so it's about the next time
it's not even about the current time
it's not the next time you know people
say okay I know which side to be on if I
want a good day that's really
interesting and we're both comedians and
one thing that I found fascinating about
Trump is that he's a disrupter when you
see him on this presidential debate but
debates like you say he's playing a
different game he's approaching it like
a stand-up comic in that he's not that
motivated by counteracting what somebody
is saying but it's almost like a
personal attack like a roast comic would
do yeah so one of his advantages
superpowers is that he doesn't recognize
boundaries
now everybody Scott is going to explain
how that's a positive here we go there
it goes without saying that depending on
the context
it could be very negative but in the
context of having a leader you say to
yourself you know is he willing to do
the hard stuff
so the first evidence of that was when
or very early on people said would you
meet with Kim Jong gun and he said sure
sure I'll be with him I'll be with
anybody and then he doesn't like wise
you know his personal insults well
you're not really supposed to do that
but did it work oh yeah oh yeah it
worked so if if there's a boundary
that's you know not that well defined
and he can push through it and it might
work you can count on him to do it
there's the there's no boundaries not
willing to push through if there's
something on the other side that looks
worthwhile just to say but isn't it as
well the comedic fact it gives you
likability like you can be a complete
so-and-so but if you're funny people go
yeah yeah yeah I've talked about that
phenomenon for years you know because in
my work I'll do something that's a
little edgy and the the rule is and I
know you'll both back me up on this the
funnier it is the more you can get away
with and I'll let's call this the Dave
Chappelle effect yeah Dave Chappelle can
simply do a special and say things that
other people can say not because they
are true but because he does it so well
you say okay that's so funny that then I
get that that's the point of it the
point of it is to be funny but if you're
not funny enough people will think the
point is the point and it then you just
look like a jerk so yeah
Trump is funny enough he can get away
with things that other other people just
can't
alright well moving on from the funny
Scott let's talk about the coronavirus
situation because it's obviously a huge
issue right now and there's been a lot
of criticisms of the way that Donald
Trump is handled there you've criticized
him on some aspects even though
generally speaking I think you're as you
said you support most of what he's doing
so on first of all on the Trump
specifically what do you make of the way
that he has handled there and the way
that he is handling
well first let me say that every
criticism of anybody who's a leader in
this field or even citizens are just
respondents any criticism that says you
should have done something sooner it
just makes me crazy
because you know what else you should
have done sooner everything good hmm
everything in the world that's good
absolutely should have and in almost
every case could have been done sooner
there's no exception to that so when
somebody says Trump should have done
this or that sooner yeah you know who
else should have done something sooner
you me me maybe I should have gone out
and gotten that again the mask a little
sooner maybe I should have you know
bought my toilet paper a little sooner
maybe I should have spoke it out a
little bit sooner maybe I should have
protected my neighbor a little bit
sooner we're all guilty of not being
soon enough so I reject every didn't
happen soon enough
now that's said and by the way that
other countries didn't prepare any
better than the United States if they
did I'd say well you know all the other
countries did it you know that would be
a valid criticism but that's just not
the case so what he did right I'd say he
acted very quickly on closing the China
Travel which really told the country
what this was I mean that that was a
statement that said this is no joke yeah
we're closing the the airports from
China so that was good and the European
closure I thought again that was the
right move I think that he has
demonstrated that he's listening to the
experts he doesn't write in public you
see him standing next to him they tell
the story of him again this is visual
persuasion I think how visual this is
you heard this story that you know the
two top medical experts found she and
Burks came in and they said and they
literally leaned this is how the story
was told leaned over the table
you know the desk and the Oval Office
and you just see this picture and showed
him the graphs and the statistics of how
many people would be dead if he doesn't
do what they were wanting him to do and
then he decided to do it and then he
told the world and he told the whole
process and we saw the whole throat
process we saw him totally embracing the
view that we just got to get back to
work because the you know the outcome
could be bad you saw him really
embracing that and then you saw the
whole transition of listening to the
experts seem that the numbers and their
scariest form possibly two million
people dead and then you see him
changing his mind I'm gonna say there's
nothing there's nothing that makes me
more confident in the leader than
watching them change their mind or
watching the whole trail you know if you
didn't know why well then you got some
questions but if you watch the whole
trail and we're playing along like this
is a this is not a spectator sport this
is really the first time everybody's
involved that gives me confidence and I
think that he's shown a willingness to
make hard decisions that would not be
popular you shown they use following the
experts and he's shown very clearly the
he's valuing every single life as equal
to every other life which is exactly
what you want your leader to say even if
they have to make tough decisions later
and you know they do he's gonna make
decisions that he knows will you know
these people will die these people will
live it's just the nature of the job but
he's willing to do that and I think he's
showing strength and the communication
that we're getting is really exceptional
he's over communicating which is the
only way to do it you know you need to
over communicate you got to err on that
side and he's doing it so I would give
him pretty pretty high and works now if
you want to hear some criticisms and I
knew do you do you know the the CDC over
here and and the World Health
Organization and even our own Surgeon
General have all just lied to our faces
for a few weeks telling us that masks
would not be helpful for the common
person and that they should be reserved
now everybody heard that knew that was a
lie you know maybe you know not not
right off the bat but I think the day I
heard it I said well that's clearly a
lie if the problem is
stuff coming out of people's mouths and
landing on things and infecting them if
you put a barrier over it even if it's
not the best barrier in the world
clearly stuff coming out of your mouth
is going to be lessened I mean - any
idiot would know that at this point you
know the country has wised up you see
that even the news people say nope that
would disagree with every legitimate
study I think they're they're
referencing that one study that seemed
to be on their side or something but
that's just a lie now I think the
intention of the lie was because of
supply you know they don't want people
hoarding the masks and in a similar
thing with the Hydrox chloroquine I
think we'll find out that that was
played down because they didn't want
people to hoard it now that's ok but
it's not my preference my preference
would be it's an emergency it's all
hands on board if I see you wearing a
mask in public all our doctors don't
have one somebody's going to talk to you
it might be your neighbor I mean no he's
gonna beat you up but somebody's gonna
ask you why are you wearing an n95 mask
if we know the hospital doesn't have an
Alfia where'd you get yours so I think
he could have told us the truth meaning
the president in the sense that he was
letting the experts lied to us he had to
know he had to know they were lying so
that that's on his permanent record you
know you can't change that that's
something that I think was it was a
judgment call
then maybe protecting the supply was
more important than being that honest at
that moment maybe it just wasn't my
choice I'm gonna want you a question
Scott and forgive me if I don't know all
the intricacies of American politics and
correct me if I'm wrong but isn't part
of the difficulty of trumps situation in
that he's not like a leader of so Boris
Johnson the UK where he's essentially
sort of governing other you know the
United Kingdom he implements his
policies everybody follows them and so
on and so forth whereas in the United
States he can implement his policies but
then Texas choose to do something
slightly different you know Alabama all
these other states or do they all
directly have to adhere to what he's
saying and what the
the Medical Council well there's a the
legal Ansel and then there's a practical
answer the legal answer of course is his
his duties are you know well described
in the state's have a lot of power and
Congress has a lot of power etc but if
you're an American and you you realize
that you're in an emergency as we all do
everybody recognizes that the president
just sort of automatically takes on
super powers even if they're not
actually anywhere I mean in other words
he can you can declare an emergency you
can you know do things he can recommend
things but I think it collectively the
that all the citizens are on board with
the fact that it's better just to have a
strong leader who's got good advisors
making decisions and I think people are
going to be really flexible about the
details of the law in an emergency you
know as soon as the emergency is over of
course we'll argue about all the details
but two-tier and I think I can answer
this the best way if there was something
that had to be done and the president
wanted it to be done in the context of
an emergency he would make it happen
okay one way or another so there's
nothing that stops the president from
getting what needs to be done as long as
the public also knows what it is and
agrees it needs to be done so he could
order order tomorrow or something that
is completely illegal
I don't know close the churches people
have said people who said that would be
illegal because of you know church and
state but he could close the churches
and then next year we'll argue whether
it was legal but yeah he could close the
churches he could do anything he wants
as long as it makes sense and we're all
watching and it's transparent wide
powers in the practical sense all right
well here's a multi trillion dollar
question scored because from watching
the Democratic debates from you know
admittedly quite far away but watching
the way that the the left has descended
into this kind of everyone's racist
everyone's sect like all this stuff that
we see partially probably coming over
from you guys to us as well we
appreciate spreading that crap around
the world
watching the Democratic debates clearly
they've settled on Joe Biden as the guy
they're gonna go with you know it was
looking know am I wrong about that well
yes and no numerically he's got a big
lead the common wisdom says yes but if
you talk to anybody who's actually got
any power any Democrat privately they'll
say we got to do something yeah we got
to do something and you know it nobody
even needs to finish the sentence mmm
it's so obvious to everyone then if you
say yeah Joe Biden we're gonna have to
do something everybody knows what that
means sure yeah yeah you know and I'm
I'm walking this fine balance I think I
might have been probably one of the
first people to say publicly hey there's
something wrong with that guy you know
you better watch that that's real that's
like medical that's a problem
yeah because we don't like to say that
in public but I didn't and feel the need
to hold back on that and then I reached
the point where I thought okay now it's
just it looks like elder or abuse I mean
actually all right not joking looks like
elder abuse yeah they just seem sad and
I thought maybe we just need to give his
the people who were close to him time to
do what needs to be done and every
everybody knows what needs to be done
you know it doesn't even have to be
stated and I waited and I waited in two
weeks go by and he's clearly declining
right in front of us I mean it's just
obvious that the rate of decline is
pretty fast right now and I can't hold
back anymore like I can't wait for
somebody else to make the decision
because I don't feel like the country
cannot have a back-up plan because right
now you know the back-up plan if the
president's in office is the vice
president and our vice president is
pretty strong free solid guy that's fine
but what if it happens between you know
now in the election you know what if our
president gets taken off the field he
could get you could get covent you know
he could anything he's a certain age
don't we need at least the other party
to have somebody who could function I
mean it's a pretty I'm pretty permissive
about who it is it's not even the party
I would necessarily be voting for
but they need somebody who's like the
spare tire there and they don't have
that and I think the country is really
exposed and even the president said it
himself the president said he didn't
think Biden was capable and would prefer
to run against the governor of New York
with the moment has a ninety-degree
approval rating and would actually make
a great president in my opinion yeah
right well this is my point irrespective
I mean yes Joe Biden I think yeah I
completely share your analysis from what
I've seen you know just cognitively he's
you know he's losing his touch which is
a pity to say about a you know a
diligent public servant whatever you may
think about his policies but my point
more broadly was irrespective actually
of who the Democrats were going to
nominate he was looking very much like
the economy was booming everything was
going great Donald Trump was gonna get
reelected that's what I saw I think
that's what you saw how do you think
this current situation changes that if
at all do you think this this
everything's up for grabs now or do you
think he's still gonna win well I'll
tell you what I said three months ago
and in three years ago which is you can
make a prediction but then you have to
add unless something big changes right
[Laughter]
and then the thing I add after unless
something big changes and something big
will change well it's the only thing
that's guaranteed is something big was
going to happen and here we are I
wouldn't be surprised if three or four
or ten more big things happen before
November so you can't really make the
prediction however if every things stay
the same as it is now and let's say we
we get to the other side of this roughly
the way people think we will economy
takes the hit but we survived the only
thing I can see is a complete blowout I
think it's going to be one of the
greatest if nothing changed and it will
[Laughter]
it would probably be the all-time
greatest blowout because if he runs
against Biden he's coming off of dealing
with emergencies successfully even if
people people are you know arguing about
the details of the timing it's gonna
look successful because every country
will probably succeed you know
it's just hard I don't know how it's
anything but the biggest blowout in the
history of politics oh really
so you don't think that with this
current health crisis it will show up in
the Americans Minds the average American
to be like look we need socialized
health care therefore we need to vote
Democrat therefore we need to take our
policies in a more sort of socialist
direction but here's the funny thing
that happened a funny thing happened on
the way to the the virus which is their
president Trump went full socialists for
now right he just said we'll pay for
your coronavirus treatment doesn't
matter who you are you just said we're
gonna give you massive amounts of money
whether you're working or not we're
gonna backstop these small businesses
and stuff so the entire country who was
thinking hey we should be trying these
more socialist things they just watched
the most you know Republican capitalist
presidents say yep you know under these
conditions full socialism for now and I
think that really softens up the other
side to say okay I guess we just have to
make a better argument because that's
what I took yeah yes this is the better
argument and then the people say oh yeah
that's a good argument we'll do that the
other the other things I think nobody is
talking about but it's really big in in
our psychology and it goes like this at
the end of this there's an I hope this
doesn't happen it looks like it's going
to happen President Trump could be broke
because the the Trump business depends
on people you know buying property and
staying in those properties and I don't
know how many are you know owned
outright and you know what the licensing
situations are and how that flows
through but there's a really good chance
that the president bankrupted himself as
well as other rich people with hotels
and recreation business in in the
service of rescuing the people who
didn't have much and even though maybe
he didn't have any choice I mean it was
going to happen anyway
the way it's gonna feel is that he
bankrupted his own most precious
resource and didn't even blink didn't
even blink save the country would be the
narrative to save the the people who
needed saving the the lowest you know
people on the economic spectrum I think
that's gonna happen now I'd love to see
that his and all the other companies you
know find a way out he's got a pretty
good balance sheet he says I don't know
if it's good enough but you know these
are enormous psychological changes that
are our brains are being rewired in real
time I mean you can feel it the way you
feel about your fellow citizens the way
you feel about politics what you feel
about your your leaders it's all
different and when we come out of this a
lot of our assets will look similar but
we won't be the same people anymore and
what does that do you know what what
kind of a civilization do we build after
relief we're done rewiring ourselves
you've talked about rewiring are some
Scott and I felt myself in that process
if somebody realized I'm somebody who is
intensely career focused driven you know
working six nights a week as a comedian
you know putting this show with
Constantine and building that and all of
a sudden you realize that actually what
is important in life isn't the career
isn't the things you surround yourself
with but actually the people who around
you your loved ones your family your
friends and I found myself more than one
I think all of us have reconnecting with
our friends in our family do you think
we're gonna see a more communitarian the
United States when we come out of this
well I would say that people revert to
being people you know in the long run
but we still as a civilization there's
there's kind of a global mind that does
keep learning so I think there's gonna
be a solid ten percent we keep you know
that the things we learned what we
learned about ourselves and our family
what was important you know to your
point learning what mattered there's
like a something I'm going through right
now because I you know I'm looking at
you know newspapers being devastated by
this I don't think many of
we'll be even in business after after
this is over so my entire career and
income and everything just just blew up
and I don't think it's ever coming back
if you'd said to me three months ago
yeah hey you'll lose all of your income
and it'll never come back I would have
been pretty depressed but I I like
everybody else I'm experiencing a
redefinition of what matters and it
doesn't feel like it matters as much as
they used to I mean I want to eat and
all that stuff but you know certainly
the you know the way I felt about it has
changed we have feel better of the
people now I'm actually in full social
isolation so I'm in a I'm in a very
large house and it's just me and my dog
and my cat and I probably won't touch
another human actually even touch for
maybe a period of three months even my
fiance is in a different house for for
safety reasons and you really learning a
lot about who you are and what you care
about it's it's a completely
transformational experience for me I
don't know if everybody's having this
but I think a lot of us will know is
gonna say it's interesting because
Francis is on his own and I'm with my
wife so I'm having a very different
experience to most people I've quit
smoking quit smoking I get daily
exercise right which I never used to do
I go to bed at the right time I mean
coronavirus has been great for my health
person they're happy to say but yeah
right but I do think it makes you think
about stuff and we will come out of it
different that's one of the things
Francis and I will really keep keen to
talk to you about is what are the
psychological shifts that are going to
happen as a result of this because the
reality is I think given the financial
packages that we've had you know you
mentioned the Donald Trump going full
socialist we had an election a few
months ago in this country where the
left was ridiculed and mocked the Labour
Party which is kind of the equivalent of
the Democrats for promising lots of you
know free bro
abandoned this and that and and the
conservative so like the Republicans
were saying well there's no magic money
tree right and it's been three months
and suddenly there's magic money forests
that we've discovered right
so it's I mean the one of our recent
guests was just saying economics doesn't
work anymore the world will be different
the world economically will be a whole
different place as a result of what
what's happening and how else is it
going to change what are going to be
some of the shifts that we're going to
see on the kind of civilization level do
you think as a result is because one of
the things we've talked a lot about on
this show is you know woke culture and
all of this kind of stuff you know
obsession about identity increasingly
smaller little identifies of who you're
this transgender person you know that
doesn't seem to matter quite so much
when we're all you know in isolation and
people are dying because we don't have
enough ventilators yeah and the other
thing that this reminded us of I hope
it's happening in your country as well
but all of that stuff just disappeared
because it's an emergency you know when
I was telling you a story on my
periscope earlier that when I asked the
young woman in my neighborhood to do
some grocery shopping for me she didn't
ask me who I voted before I don't care
who she voted for and if there's
somebody in my neighborhood who needs
help later and I can provide it I'm not
going to ask them their politics either
and I I was saying this morning that
everything is too quiet there there's
there's a just today not yesterday or
any other day but there's some kind of
quiet that happened that I could just
feel it's like it's in the zeitgeist is
in the air or something and part of it
is a lack of conflict within the country
that you look at the headlines I'm
looking for all the stories about who a
to and whose insult and they're there
but they're very mild like it's you know
it's from a ten it sounds like a three
just to fill some space I mean it looked
like they were just saying can you guys
come up with something to complain about
because you know we need to fill some
space here it looked like they were
forcing it like nobody's heart is in it
right now right
Viceroy this article the other day about
how the worst thing about the corona
virus is that it's denying trans people
a life-saving transition surgery and I
think everyone just looked at it kind of
what come on guys this is not the thing
to be talking about right now so I know
exactly what you mean we so what you're
really saying is we are less angry or
potentially becoming less angry with
each other and less divided yeah and I
don't think if you're low-income I don't
think you it can be missed on you that
you're not the one who's going to be
paying it back all this money that's
coming toward you the the rich basically
just emptied their pockets and that's
exactly what you didn't expect right
because you think the rich are gonna
take care of themselves and stuff now of
course there's self-interest right
you know the rich can live in the
country if the whole country disappears
well I don't think anybody had to ask
you know you saw it let everybody from
Jeff Bezos do you know you name it Elon
Musk there was nobody who didn't jump in
and it's gonna be super expensive for a
lot of billionaires nobody's crying for
him there's they're losing billions and
billions and you know sometimes tens of
billions I don't think they blinked I
don't think anybody blinked it's like
yeah if that's what it takes to get
things wrote that will do that so I
think everybody sort of stepped up you
know and in what they could do we're
seeing a display of human ingenuity in
in terms of you know how to materialize
ventilators and and nothing you know
engineers are just like breaking rules
of physics at this point and I think
what we feel about ourselves will change
I think what we think we need to do
about you know supply lines and trade
what we need to do to prepare for the
next major you know problem whether it's
an epidemic or not just a lot of stuffs
getting stronger it's just not the
economy at the moment but that will come
back do you envisage that coming back
all because I've seen a lot of hot takes
from people which I find quite
frustrating about how actually we're
gonna
it's gonna be a you know we're gonna
come into a mass depression it's gonna
mean that society is gonna be fractured
or do you see it or do you take a more
sort of upbeat tone as to what will
happen when we emerge well I might be
the most upbeat of all the upbeat people
I like I like whenever I can bet on
human beings figuring it out you know
under pressure like I always take that
bet you know it when when the year 2000
bug was coming I just said all right
seriously the smartest people in the
world can't figure out how to write some
programs that go in and look for that
thing and fix it really the whole world
doesn't have people smart enough to do
that and when he got close to the
deadline the smart people wrote programs
and went look for those things and
changes and those the whole thing was he
just had to get the smart people engaged
and fixed it so I think we're seeing
some version of that you know more
desperate a bigger bigger problem here
but the the level of a talent and
brilliance that's being focused on this
everywhere in the world is it's
breathtaking and I don't think we'll
ever see anything like this again
so you see more people coming together
isn't it amazing
in a way how it's needed a killer virus
to make us all forget the fact that our
petty insecurities and differences yeah
you know I've always been amazed that
people who went through let's say a war
together they could be separated for 30
years but they're never separated like
you know if you were in the foxhole with
with your your buddy you saved each
other's lives or whatever you're never
really separated and there's something
about this which is all of humanity
fighting fighting this virus that we we
just formed connections some of them
will you know disappear in the future
we'll get if when times are good we'll
get back to our petty differences I feel
like the profile will all have gone
through the same experience a shared
experience everybody chipped in
you know everybody did what they could
and I think you're always going to know
that
now you know I use I use the example of
France I could like use Great Britain in
this book Frances a cleaner example
France doesn't really ever have to
wonder if they were to get let's say
attacked by some external force whether
the United States would have their back
or would I wonder if France would have
the United States for France but for the
United States and France have a history
which strongly suggests we will have
each other's back right yeah and
although I've never been in a situation
where I needed France or vice-versa and
you know my lifetime still well I know
that it's true because he history
rewrites your brains in a certain way
you go oh well if it were this other
country maybe not but France
well obviously obviously because France
you know France would do it for us of
course we'll do it so there's something
like that going on globally where you're
hearing your neighbors the Democrats etc
today it was there was some news that
Chris Cuomo who was one of the most
prominent CNN personalities tested
positive for the corona virus I don't
think anybody had a bad feeling about it
but you know three months ago you know
every Republican and Trump supporter
would have wanted to dump on them and
just say every every horrible thing you
could say just because of his politics
but not today today people saw that and
they said get well soon
wow that's that's exciting because in
the UK as you probably know our Prime
Minister our health secretary a lot of
senior people involved in fighting
coronavirus have actually got it and we
still had a huge number of people on
Twitter coming out and going how you
know how delighted they are how you know
all this kind of stuff so maybe maybe
you guys are ahead of us on that one
which one which is nice to hear but
coming back to the divided global world
for a moment you're someone who I think
I don't know I don't know you if you
self-described yourself as a China hawk
but I don't think it would be inaccurate
to say that you you've been critical of
China on
different aspects of this and more
broadly without first of all would that
be right that fair yes for a context my
stepson died of a in overdose in 2018 in
fentanyl was in his system fentanyl
comes from China with the Chinese
government approval ships into Mexico in
their precursor form and then the
cartels turn it into drugs and send it
up to our country to kill a lateral
seventy thousand people a year or so so
given that the government of China
clearly knows and they they know who's
sending it they know the laboratory is
coming from CBS went over there for 60
minutes and found the guy in interview
so of course the government of China
knows who he is and of course they're
letting it happen still so under those
conditions China has to be considered an
enemy and I would consider this
basically a hot war because you know
we're dying by the tens of thousands
through their actions deliberate actions
so yes I would like the government of
China to be erased from the earth I like
the people people of China great yeah
so the CCP's is the issue but they
haven't exactly where I was taking this
is they haven't exactly covered
themselves in glory with with could the
coronavirus they covered it up for a
period of time as a result of which very
likely it got out in a way that
otherwise it wouldn't have got out what
do you think will be the actually before
I let me ask something else people like
you who predicted that Donald Trump
would be elected quite early seem also
to be the same people who have predicted
the corona virus and got people to take
people like Steve Bannon Mike CERN of
etc all you guys seem to have been aware
of this in a way that most people went
why is that is that random yeah you know
I've seen that observation before and
you're absolutely right there there's a
complete correlation and some of it I
think well I'll just talk about the
individuals you mentioned Mike Serna
Mitch can just see around corners so it
has nothing to do with these two
examples you
just is better at this he just sees the
bigger field he has a more impressive
talent stack you know from psychology to
economics to law he just sees the field
Steve Bannon same thing he's just
smarter in in my case you know I may
have been influenced by my hatred for
China again hatred for the government of
China not the people who are awesome
so I can't explain it but I would say
that maybe there's something about the
non-standard thinkers that gives us some
kind of advantage
because we're we're more likely to buck
the mainstream you buy by personality as
much as anything else so um yeah you
should watch for that and by the way you
know if you're taking and Saeb and and
and sort of it's just as you're two
examples these are just the two things
they got right right these are people
with a pretty big body of knowing stuff
before other people know it it's not a
coincidence they're just better at it
and do you think we're gonna reach the
stage once we sort of get past this is
weekly inevitably will move the human
race we'll get over this where we put
China under some pretty heavy pressure
for reparations well you know there will
be noise for that I don't think
President Trump will ever use that term
because he's he's got this weird balance
where he wants to be friendly with the
leadership which i think is a good
strategy no matter what you think of
them it's a good strategy but at the
same time i think i dont know how
obvious it is from from your perspective
over there but can i swear you
absolutely [ __ ] can sometimes where
you have to you think you think it's
optional but let me just explain the
american mood so you understand it it
has nothing to do with what our you know
our government may or may not tell us to
do the mood here is there's no [ __ ]
way we're going to do business with
China unless you put a gun to our head
from now on period so every everybody
who can move their supply chain and
any cost will do it if they don't do it
they're gonna have to answer to
Americans all right because we're done
so good luck if you want to keep doing
your business over in China because
we're going to turn it over we're going
to look at the label and we're not going
to pick your [ __ ] product if it says
China on it so the supply chains are
coming back that should be an enormous
economic blow to China I don't even know
if it's good for us you know cuz it'll
cost more so you know it's hard to
nobody's smart enough to know the
plusses and minuses but in terms of
security we just have to do it it's no
longer well that's one of the point you
point you've made repeatedly which is
you know it's not sustainable to have a
situation where you know 97% of our
antibiotics come from China you know
yeah that's one of those arguments that
will pretend were arguing over here but
it's already decided that stuff's coming
home I don't know how long or quickly
but yeah there may be a pretend argument
but that's coming home and Scott you so
you said and you use a phrase it's
coming home which I find very very
interesting do you think with the crisis
what we're going to see is essentially
the death blow to globalization where
people used to believe well not everyone
but a lot of people used to believe in
particular people in power the
globalization was this universal good
that the more connected we are the
better we are as a society but actually
what this is showing is that it in many
ways it makes us more vulnerable yeah
and I think it depends on the product
you know if you're making widgets or
ashtrays or something it probably
doesn't matter where you make them so
just find some low cost people but if
it's anything important to the function
of your country people are going to
bring that in and the other thing that
you can't quite predict at this point is
the psychological change that will
happen when the entire argument for
however many months this goes on is
going to be about closing borders now of
course it's closing borders for a
specific reason the virus but the the
mental model
of closing borders to keep danger out
when from a concept that people were on
both sides to at least for a while a
concept where everybody says okay and
that does make sense when you're talking
about a virus now people are not
normally viruses or virus carriers so
it's it's it's an analogy thinking and
it's not logical thinking because you
should just treat every situation like
it's its own thing but the way people
are we use analogies and they influence
us so I think I think the notion that
well I think watching the fact that
everybody agrees closing traffic between
countries made a difference so I think
all the experts no matter their
political affiliation will say yeah it's
good we stop travel in these situations
I think that's just gonna make people a
little more open to the argument that
there might be other reasons to have
borders as well so so yeah I think that
will move the argument away from
globalization not completely of course I
suppose the other thing we're seeing as
well is that you know we mostly have
shower borders to some extent and yet
society hasn't crumbled into dust so
people will kind of look at that and go
well maybe you know our natural
predilection to think all closing
borders or reducing immigration is you
know this kind of unquestionable evil I
think those people don't really have a
leg to stand on anymore yeah and also
you know maybe we can get out of the
binary of the borders or either closed
or not closed nobody there's nobody in
this country who wants a closed border
we just want to know who's coming in and
we want to be the ones who decide yes
it's our house we get to decide who
comes in
sounds pretty racist to me so obviously
I'm joking so we've been talking about
globalization I wanted to talk with you
in particular about the phenomenon of
the strongman the populist leader which
we've seen right away from you know the
America right way through Europe and
Modi in India now in there in a world
where it's become all of a sudden
very very very uncertain very very
worrying are we gonna crave those type
of strong men figures more well did you
say strong men I mean way to woke to put
let's revise that to strong women and
sometimes people I believe we like to
say people's gut I've Justin Trudeau who
famously told us and the answer is I
think yes I mean that would be the the
natural inclination is if you feel
threatened by an external force you want
bad and if things are good and you want
to have a little more sharing in the
household you want mom and that you know
I think things are as simple as we you
know our leaders are a mom or a dad
basically and it could be either party
and either gender you know so I'm not
gender izing this I'm just saying that
classic dad is the guy who gets the
baseball bat if there's a if there's a
noise downstairs could be mom a mom
could be loaded you know she could she
could ever handgun to but usually
classically you think it's the the man
who's gonna go down just cuz he's bigger
so yeah I think we'll see strong leaders
have a little bit of a upsurge thanks
for watching guys as always subscribe to
the youtube channel click the bell
button next to subscribe button so you
get notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word